I'm in this level of murder
that's happened a lot of
parts of Latin American now.
It's crazy.
But in these areas is in as what he
talked to other people who are just on the
edge of this or have family members
involved in this and it's just they're
living this,
I mean,
these are levels of violence and it's
interesting to compare historically these
levels of violence.
Um,
because you look at some of the worst
cities like San Pedro Sula on Doris
Caracas,
um,
Ciudad Juarez and these are places
which have levels of violence,
which are like way worse
than medieval Europe.
A lot of places in medieval Europe,
I mean,
look at the figures per hundred thousand
because some of them have over a
hundred, a hundred thousand, 150,
100,000 and met Eva Europe Lot.
These cities were like 20 per hundred
thousand. So they're way worse than that.
Way Worse than the wild west than like
now there are some place in the United
States that de la, oh, an idea. And I've
done some research recently in Baltimore,
Maryland and I was kind of,
it's interesting to compare that to
Latin America and that's a high level.
That's 40 a hundred thousands that's not
as the same level, but it's significant.
Still more than medieval
Europe. Yeah. Wow. Baltimore's
worse than Medieval Europe.
Yeah.
I'm an advocate.
You have to have to some professors then
they weren't in a like you get like,
you know, they might be, they might say,
well Jerusalem in this time or in a line
I let you got to try and free. Nice.
Hard to know. Really dig down. Exactly.
And that there was outbreaks of
violence and killing in certain places.
The overall average of all
the average year, that's a
significant leap. 100% leap.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Baltimore.
What about South side of Chicago?
It's not that,
I mean like the level I think in Chicago
comes out around 20 or something,
so it's not now the Emerg that of
the host city. Now these again,
and one of the things about the violence
in the United States compared to Latin
America in Baltimore is, is, is,
is significant bits of fairly,
well, the city of Baltimore is a fairly
small place where they're talking about,
so in Mexico you have entire states
that are like really violent or entire
countries in Latin America,
whereas in the U s it tends to be
neighborhoods which are violent. Um,
so if you really focus on
the south side of Chicago,
it's probably similar levels
to Baltimore then United, sir.
But if you look at the whole city,
you've got neighbors that are
pretty safe in Chicago as well.